PROFESSOR: So as a
more technical aside,
let's analyze more
carefully the problem
of release of viral load from
a drop by process of diffusion.
So here, again, I
sketch a droplet,
which would typically be an
aerosol droplet in the size
range of, let's say, microns.
And the virion of
interest has a size
that is much smaller than that
on the order of, let's say,
100 nanometers.
And this white path is showing
how such a virion would
go from its initial position R,
let's say, as a radio position,
to the boundary.
Now, the general
problem of finding
the expected first passage time
from the point inside a domain
to a boundary is a
classical problem
in the theory of stochastic
processes and random walks.
And it has the following
representation.
So the mean are
expected first passage
time from a point to
an absorbing surface
solves the following problem.
Is the Laplacian of that
time with a minus sign
is 1 over D where D
is the diffusivity.
And so this is the DV
that I described before,
the diffusivity of the virion.
And the boundary condition
for this equation
is that it's an absorbing
boundary, basically.
So when the virion gets
to the surface it's gone.
And that's when the
stochastic process finishes.
So it's tau equals 0 on
radius capital R, which
is the radius of the droplets.
So that's on the boundary.
So in the case of a
spherical drop, then
we can write this equation
in spherical coordinates.
So that's minus 1 over
r-squared, r derivative
of r-squared D
tau DR. And that's
equal to 1 over capital D.
And then again, our
boundary condition
is the tau of capital
R is equal to zero.
Another boundary condition we might
mention is that D tau DR at R
equals 0 is zero.
That's a symmetry
boundary condition.
So when you're right in
the middle, basically,
there should be no--
there's no favorite direction
for the diffusion process.
And so, therefore, the
derivative this time
with respect to R must
be 0 at the center
because it's a symmetry
boundary condition.
OK, so we can now go ahead
and solve this problem.
Let me put the r-squared on
their side and use primes
with no derivatives.
So let's write this
as r-squared tau
prime, prime equals
minus r-squared over d.
And if I now
integrate both sides,
I get r-squared
tau prime equals--
and then here we
get a minus r-cubed
over 3D plus a constant.
And that constant immigration
according to the symmetry
boundary condition has to
be 0, because tau prime is
0 at r equals 0.
So we can simplify
this and write
tau prime is minus r over 3D.
And so then I can
integrate again.
And I found that tau of r is--
well, I integrate this,
I get r squared over 2
is integral of r.
So that gives that
an r-squared over 6.
So there will be a 6
D and minus r-squared.
And there'll be a
constant integration.
And in order to satisfy this
boundary condition of vanishing
a capital R, you
can see that I can
write the constant this way.
And I'll write it as
capital R squared over 6D
is a constant of integration.
So basically, the profile of
the main first passage time
is essentially a parabola.
So as a function of distance R
from the center of the droplet,
you have this shape to the
mean transmission time.
And the maximum here,
the maximum value
is tau 0 is the maximum value.
And that is r-squared over 60.
So that's if you happen
to be unlucky and right
in the middle.
That's the longest
you would expect
to take from a particular part.
Now on the other hand,
as I've sketched here,
in a typical droplet, if
the virions are randomly
distributed, some of them,
like this guy over here,
happen to be very
close to the surface.
So you're not going to have
to wait this long for them
to escape.
So now we can ask the question,
what is the average escape
time over all the initial
positions of the virus,
or virion, assuming that
the virions are uniformly
distributed at random in
the initial condition.
So if we do that, then
we're solving for the--
that's all [INAUDIBLE],,
so I'll put it over here.
The average escape time or
first passage time for the virus
will be tau bar.
Well, what I'll do is
I'll integrate over
all the positions and
then divide by the volume
because a uniform distribution.
So I'll write the
integral over the volume
as 4 pi, the solid angle times
integral from 0 to capital
R of tau of r r-squared DR. And
I'll divide by the total volume
4/3 pi capital r-cubed.
OK, so if we do
this integral here,
so when we plug-in
this, first of all,
we can see that
we get, obviously,
for the constant term,
r-squared over 60,
we just have a ratio of volume
over volume, which is one.
So we get r squared
over 6D is the first term,
just integrating that constant.
But then it's 1 minus.
And then instead
of r-squared, you
have r-squared times
this r-squared.
It says r to fourth.
So you integrate that.
You get r to the fifth over 5.
And so then you get
1/5 over this 1/3 here.
And that gives you 3/5.
And so that gives, when
I subtract one minus 3/5,
I get 2/5.
And 2 over 6 is 1/3.
And so this ends up
being r-squared over 15D
as we had previously quoted.
So it's worth going through
the calculation just to see.
This number 15 is an
order of magnitude.
It's larger than 10.
So while we normally
estimate diffusion times
to be of order length
squared divided by D,
so r-squared over
d, this calculation
shows that the actual
average time is much smaller
than that by a factor of 15.
And that's precisely because
the virus virions sometimes
find themselves initially
near the surface.
So they get out more easily.
So you don't have to
wait for diffusion
across the entire drop.
That sets the overall scale.
But the average
drop diffusion time
is actually less than that.